we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a voicemail that is going to
upset people in my audience because it
is someone saying hey david
as progressives maybe we shouldn't be so
anti-cryptocurrency uh-oh this will this
will upset some people take a listen
hey david this is huvian from
minneapolis i wanted to call and commend
you on your balance stance on crypto and
nfts i'm a progressive and also a crypto
investor and i'm just saddened because i
see like so many progressive thought
leaders demonizing the entirety of
crypto without entertaining like
reasonable discourse on how to properly
regulate it i mean it's all it seems
like they're like trump-like with their
rhetoric sometimes um to me the problem
is like crypto's such a big idea
it's like the internet so like to paint
the entire sector as a ponzi or scam
rises to almost trumpian levels of uh
immaturity
it's not perfect and it needs regulation
but there's a reason this thing
continues to grow and i think there's
like i think it's here to stay and i
feel to see how progressives win by
demonizing it
i mean
they might even win like some votes by
helping lead the discussion on
reasonable regulatory policy
yeah listen this is this is really
painful to me that there is such a lack
of balance from many of my uh friends on
the left on this issue of cryptocurrency
um it's almost like it's a trigger word
you hear cryptocurrency or you hear the
word bitcoin and it's immediately like
no bad scam illegal crime
right away
um and there's also kind of like a
naivete or maybe an arrogance to think
that you know the future of this entire
space that you know whether this is
something that's going to be viable or
not i think some humility should tell us
we don't know and that's kind of the
whole point
cryptocurrency is clearly here to stay
to some degree
been around more than a decade major
wall street financial advisories now say
to most people
it's not unreasonable to have you know
one to three two to four percent of
assets in cryptocurrency for
diversification it's it's volatile but
it's been around a long time there are
cryptocurrency etfs moving in the
direction of mutual funds
we don't have to like it but the idea
that any second it's going to evaporate
seems increasingly unlikely
now i think the other thing that's
important is
a lot of the bullet points and and again
just as a reminder
i don't care about cryptocurrency any
more than i care about mutual funds or
stocks like i want to just have
a properly diversified
asset allocation for my risk tolerance
with my money that that's all i care
about
um
sometimes you'll hear well crypto is
mostly being held by wealthy people
right just like the us dollar i mean you
know this this is a systemic problem
money is mostly in the hands of the
wealthy that's not unique to
cryptocurrency so that is that really
the issue not to me
um is crypto used to complete criminal
transactions yeah some i mean apparently
not that much one interesting thing was
when the silk road got shut down it was
believed
that the silk road was basically uh
the the vast majority of of bitcoin
transactions and with with the silk road
shut down
um
bitcoin transactions would fall to
almost zero it didn't happen crypto
transactions barely declined when the
the silk road was shut down the dollar
has been used for way more crimes than
bitcoin has it's just a reality it
doesn't tell us one thing or the other
i'm not defending anything
does bitcoin mining not all crypto but
does bitcoin mining have a carbon
footprint absolutely absolutely and it's
impera i mean it's not going to be
sustainable unless that's dealt with
either through
um alternative energy like that's that's
a problem that's got to be dealt with
and also
the legacy dollar
and banking industry
has an insane carbon footprint all the
dollars that are brought by tourists to
europe
are then flown back to the us do you
understand the carbon footprint of that
armored cars everywhere insane
infrastructure of banks the overhead
they have private jets i mean
it's
if you want to talk about that let's
talk about it but let's also consider
other banking and monetary instruments
in the carbon footprint
people hear this and they go but it's
not the same well just compare one by
one and my view on crypto is nothing is
only good
the internet oh my god child porn scams
right but the internet exists and it's
going to exist so we've got to control
the child porn and the scams the stock
market it's rife with scammers fake
financial advisors ponzi schemes yes we
have to deal with that but
investors
investing in the stock market's not
going to end uh
you know cars i mean they
they put out emissions and people die in
car accident yeah but liz but cars are
going to exist is that we're not at this
point we're not getting rid of cars so
let's make them green let's switch to
electric let's make them safer let's
redesign our roads
i'm not even an evangelist that it
crypto exists it doesn't seem to be
going anywhere
i put a small portion of my assets in
monthly dating back to 2015
and that's it i don't have all my eggs
in there if crypto ends and goes to zero
i lose what is now three to five percent
if it does well then i do it it it's not
something in and of itself that we
should have this
reflexive reaction to
and the problem is that when the left
takes that view
they just miss out on participating in
how to properly regulate crypto and they
leave it to i don't know the
libertarians or whoever let's take a
more balanced view please we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpakman.com
i will see you then